hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
chile acude a las urnas para elegir a
los redactores de su nueva constitución
una jornada electoral considerada como
la más importante en tres décadas de
democracia y que nació tras la presión
ciudadana en las calles y supera un
histórico plebiscito aunque fue aplazado
por la pandemia se celebró en octubre de
2020 bajo estrictas medidas sanitarias
mientras tanto en colombia los
ciudadanos siguen presionando a iván
duque en las calles por tercera semana
consecutiva la mesa de diálogo que
convocó está estancada y los ciudadanos
siguen pidiendo reformas de fondo que
terminen con la histórica inequidad
social y el rechazo al uso excesivo de
la fuerza por parte de la policía
alimentado ahora por el repudio a la
violencia sexual contra las mujeres por
parte de oficiales
y vamos de inmediato a chile para
nuestra historia principal
los chilenos finalmente deciden quiénes
serán los constituyentes los que
escribirán el conjunto de normas que los
regirán en adelante reemplazando a la
carta magna de augusto pinochet a la
jornada estaba prevista para abril pero
fue aplazada debido al alza de contagios
de kobe 19
todo empezó en octubre de 2019 cuando
miles de ciudadanos se tomaron las
calles en rechazo al aumento del precio
del pasaje del transporte público pues
se trataba de la mayor alza de tarifas
en la historia reciente un incremento de
30 pesos chilenos que llevaba la tarifa
a 830 pesos poco más de un dólar de la
época estudiantes llamaron a los
ciudadanos a no pagar el pasaje y al
margen de las movilizaciones pacíficas
se registraron actos de vandalismo una
semana después varias estaciones del
metro de santiago fueron destruidas por
lo que el gobierno de sebastián piñera
desplegó a la policía lo que le derivó
en enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
uniformados y una brutal represión
veamos el siguiente informe
el 18 de octubre chile estalló en
protesta sábado
lo que empezó por un reclamo en contra
del aumento del precio del pasaje del
transporte público derivó en una
exigencia por cambios de fondos en las
políticas gubernamentales que durante
décadas profundizaron la desigualdad
30 pesos en la tarifa del metro y 10 en
la de autobuses un cambio que para los
chilenos no refleja un incremento en sus
ingresos y que llegaba después de
aumentos al precio de la luz y el agua y
se sumaba a un rechazo de años a los
sistemas de salud educación y pensiones
que al estar en manos privadas agrandan
la ya inmensa brecha entre ricos y
pobres
los estudiantes pidieron a los
ciudadanos sumarse a las evasiones
masivas levantar el torniquete del metro
y entrar sin pagar y siguieron
protestando día a día noche a noche sin
descanso
los ciudadanos salieron a las calles a
presionar al gobierno hasta lograr
convocar a más de un millón de personas
en la conocida como la mayor marcha de
chile en torno a plaza italia que fue
rebautizada como la plaza de kinect al
margen de las manifestaciones pacíficas
se registraron saqueos a supermercados
quemadas estaciones de transporte y
actos vandálicos lo que llevó al
presidente sebastián piñera a ordenar el
despliegue de los militares quienes
empezaron a lanzar gases lacrimógenos en
contra de los ciudadanos y terminaron
disparando perdigones pero no se
rindieron
la violencia en las calles llevó a que
piñera a decretar el estado de
emergencia y el toque de queda y aunque
dio marcha atrás en el alza al precio
del pasaje el reclamo ya había
trascendido
indiana
el hijo de los implacables que no
respeta a nada ni a nadie que está
dispuesto a usar la violencia
bullying
lejos de disiparse las protestas se
fortalecieron el mandatario chileno
anunció un paquete de medidas para
aliviar las desigualdades que no calmó
el descontento con los militares en las
calles las imágenes de la represión
dieron la vuelta al mundo
el gobierno chileno confirmó la muerte
de 18 personas pidió perdón por la
supuesta respuesta al ejecutivo a las
protestas y anunció el inicio de un
proceso para redactar una nueva
constitución que sería sometido a un
plebiscito pero no fue sino hasta
diciembre que lo promulgó por lo que las
protestas continuaron incluso hasta el
mundialmente famoso festival de viña del
mar en febrero de 2020 solo el
coronavirus pudo contener el estallido
en 5 meses desde el 19 de octubre al 19
de marzo de 2020 460 personas reportaron
lesiones oculares por perdigones o
bombas lacrimógenas
en el mundo se registraron 310 en 17
años de 1990 a 2017 según un contado de
la agencia de noticias afp
y aunque fue modificada varias veces la
constitución actual es criticada por ser
una herencia del régimen militar de
augusto pinochet pero especialmente
porque no dejan responsabilidad del
estado sino en manos privadas el
cumplimiento de los derechos básicos
como la salud o la educación veamos los
puntos polémicos de la carta magna
en el informe de valentina torres
sánchez
la actual constitución chilena que se
cambiara establece que el agua es
privada lo que no ocurre en ningún otro
país del mundo
los chilenos pagan una de las tarifas
más altas de américa latina' para
consumir agua potable que en su gran
mayoría es propiedad de empresas
transnacionales
lo mismo ocurre con los recursos
minerales la constitución permite que
compañías privadas extranjeras extraigan
los bienes naturales que son un pilar de
la economía del país como el litio y el
cobre pero sin contemplar la
participación de industrias nacionales
ni del estado
y la actual constitución también habla
del estado subsidiario lo que significa
que el estado vigila a los particulares
que prestan los servicios de salud
educación o seguridad social pero no
provee directamente las prestaciones
para que los ciudadanos accedan a ellos
los servicios públicos de salud
educación y pensiones son calificados de
precarios en el país
precisamente por eso es que la
constitución era difícil de cambiar
en la carta magna- está determinado que
cualquier modificación debe contar con
el apoyo de dos tercios de los
legisladores tanto del senado como de la
cámara lo que hace que las
modificaciones sean muy difíciles de
aprobar todo eso fue lo que impulsó el
voto mayoritario para cambiar la
constitución pues gran parte de la
población chilena asegura que es
legítimo tener una carta magna heredada
de la dictadura y por eso cuando la
propuesta de una hoja en blanco para
trazar las nuevas reglas del juego
la convocatoria para el plebiscito en el
que los ciudadanos decidirán si querían
o no una nueva constitución quedó fijada
para el 26 de abril de 2020
luego de imaginar que el coronavirus
llegaría a poner en pausa al mundo
entero por lo que la cita electoral fue
aplazada hasta el 25 de octubre en esa
histórica jornada que tuvo la
participación más alta desde que se
instauró el voto voluntario en 2012
chile decidió reescribir la constitución
de pinochet con más del 78 por ciento de
los votos y los ciudadanos volvieron a
las calles pero a celebrar
aunque marcada por las restricciones
para detener la propagación del cob y 19
la jornada del plebiscito en chile-
transcurrió con normalidad
un horario específico para los mayores
de 60 años el uso obligatorio de
mascarillas y la exigencia a cada
votante de llevar su propio bolígrafo
fueron algunas de las medidas adoptadas
en el marco de la pandemia
la votación inició con algunos retrasos
y se registraron varios intentos de
bloqueo del tránsito en santiago pero en
general la cita con la democracia se
cumplió incluso el voto en el extranjero
marcó un hito en participación el
presidente sebastián piñera aseguró que
la democracia se fortaleció tras la
jornada pero afirmó que una nueva
constitución siempre tendrá que recoger
la herencia de las generaciones
anteriores
este plebiscito no es el fin es el
comienzo de un camino que juntos todos
deberemos recorrer para acordar una
nueva constitución para chile el
plebiscito hacía dos preguntas la
primera quiere usted una nueva
constitución
los chilenos debían responder entre las
opciones apruebo y rechazó con más del
78 por ciento de los votos el apruebo
ganó es decir los chilenos eligieron
cambiar la constitución promulgada hace
40 años por augusto pinochet y el cómo
hacerlo era la segunda pregunta qué
órgano debería redactar esta nueva
constitución una convención mixta o una
convención constitucional la convención
mixta eran 172 personas distribuidas en
partes iguales entre ciudadanos electos
y parlamentarios mientras que la de una
convención constitucional de 155
miembros establecía que todos sus
integrantes fueran elegidos
específicamente para este propósito es
por eso que chile vuelve a las urnas a
elegir los en febrero se aprobó una ley
que establece que la asignación de
escaños de la asamblea constituyente
deberá garantizar la paridad
convirtiendo a chile en el primer país
en el mundo con una constitución
redactada por un número igual de mujeres
y hombres
mientras tanto colombia entró en su
tercera semana de protestas en contra
del presidente iván duque y el diálogo
entre el gobierno y los organizadores
del paro sigue estando estancado
mientras que organizaciones sociales y
no gubernamentales con el respaldo del
senador iván cepeda denunciaron ante la
corte penal internacional al presidente
a su ministro de defensa al comandante
del ejército y al director de la policía
por presuntos crímenes de lesa humanidad
cometidos durante las manifestaciones es
que según la defensoría del pueblo más
de 40 personas han fallecido por el uso
excesivo de la fuerza según el informe
que presentaron hay además 11 casos de
desaparición forzada 129 personas fueron
víctimas de tortura más de 1300 fueron
detenidas de forma irregular y hubo 16
casos de violencia sexual sobre este
último flagelo hay indignación
especialmente por el caso de una joven
de 17 años que se suicidó después de
haber sido detenida y abusada
sexualmente por cuatro integrantes de la
policía que calificó la denuncia como
falsa y ruin
la brutalidad del caso de allison
menéndez convocó a cientos de mujeres a
las calles
[Música]
[Aplausos]
la policía no me cuida me cuidan mis
amigas esta es una de las arengas que se
escuchan en las manifestaciones de
colombia para pedir justicia por las al
menos 16 mujeres que han sido víctimas
de violencia sexual en 15 días de
protestas según la ong con gloria men
estamos de luto por todo lo que ha
pasado en el marco del paro nacional en
colombia han habido
[Aplausos]
exacerbada de muertes
agresiones
tensiones y muchas picadas
en este estallido social la mayoría de
hechos de abuso policial contra las
mujeres corroborados por organizaciones
internacionales ha ocurrido cerca de
estaciones de la policía lugares que
deberían brindarles protección a el
gobierno prometió eliminar las manzanas
podridas nuestra fuerza público
actúa
con obediencia absoluta a la
constitución y la ley
todas las órdenes operativas que se
imparten siempre se enmarcan en la
garantía de los derechos humanos y si se
presentan violaciones por conductas
individuales de miembro de la fuerza
pública esta sede judicial ethan y se
investigan
según la ong temblores entre 2017 y 2019
se registraron 241 casos de violencia
sexual por parte de la fuerza pública y
la procuraduría general la encargada de
investigar y sancionar a los
funcionarios del estado no ha acusado a
ningún policía por uso excesivo de la
fuerza cometido en 2019 y 2020 menos aún
por delitos sexuales la violencia sexual
ha sido utilizada como arma de guerra en
colombia durante años según cifras de la
unidad para las víctimas desde 1985 al
menos 26 mil 534 mujeres se han visto
afectadas en el marco del conflicto
armado las violaciones fueron cometidas
por el ejército paramilitares y
guerrilleros pero aún en muchos casos
que no salieron a la luz y al margen de
las protestas apenas en los tres
primeros meses de 2001 en colombia se
registraron 158 feminicidios gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa recuerden que pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas cuídense mucho y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]